he is with us in Massachusetts hi Cassie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you good how can we help we got
a little predicament here between me and
my husband so about nine months ago or
so we moved in with my mother-in-law to
save money she offered for us to stay in
her basement for much less than we were
spending on rent and we had already
downsized the biggest issue is that
we've found that she's extremely
difficult to live with and my husband's
not super great at communication and
when it comes to finances so I feel
really really stuffed because he won't
really give me you know this is how much
we want to save to get out there's just
really a big lack of communication there
when it comes to how do you make ins I'm
going to say make income so I'm a
stay-at-home mom I have two little ones
under two and he makes about 60 K gross
why don't you just move out that's a
good question I asked him that all the
time you're asking in a way then why
isn't he here in that question well I
have weird babies up too and we have
about 10 K and student loan and metal
between the student loan and medical
debt those things are stopping Overseers
yeah yeah apparently there is the money
side why isn't he why isn't he answering
that question I think he wants good are
you asking the question when you're in a
fight or when you're frustrated or y'all
having breakfast together you just say
hey man what's the plan like what why
isn't he answering this question um
we've I've asked him many many times and
recently it's blown up into like a fight
about it and now he just doesn't want to
about it at all and we have you know had
some conversations about it but it
doesn't really go anywhere I think where
he's at is he kind of wants to be wants
to be out of debt wants to have a
certain amount down for a house before
before we move which makes sense but I
think living here is really really
stressful as well so it's there's like a
big toss up is it more stressful for you
because you're staying at home and you
don't have to deal with it yeah yeah I
think so and so all Dave you've answered
this question for 150 years on this show
I I can't I can't help that was a little
bit of a boomer joke there I can't help
but think that your husband's not
understanding not hearing you and you're
not aligned and with when it comes to
values right he doesn't understand the
pain that you're sitting in and like
doesn't understand that the emotional
cost you got to move you got to get out
of the house yeah I I feel that in my
court I really really feel it in my core
we did take financial piece this past
November after we moved in here and
you're like yes we're doing the right
thing we moved to save money
mother-in-law's basement not one time no
but we thought that you know moving it
gave us the amount of space that we
needed for two kids because I was
pregnant with our second and we did not
have space at the current place that we
were at and we were like oh this is
great we'll save money for our house but
now it's to the point where I don't
think it's worth it anymore and he's
like but we're still in baby step two
that's great but your house you made it
you you tried something you went for it
it was a it seemed like a cool idea it
sounded great on the back of a napkin
and now your marriage is suffering for
it and your trust in each other is
suffering for it your two kids are
absorbing your attention they're
absorbing your y'all's dysfunction and
you got to move okay and you have to
speak to him the only person in this you
can control
was you and you have to speak to him in
a way that he can hear it and waiting
til there's a fight or you say we've
we've I keep bringing it up bringing it
up the the other side that were the the
negative where there is nagging and
nagging somebody never gets somebody it
never gets what you want and so you've
got to find a place well it's getting
off site well it's leaving the kids with
mother-in-law and going somewhere and
sitting down and saying it's not an if
it's when we move and I'm about to put a
date on a calendar to get my kids out of
this thing and I want you to be a part
of this with us and we've got to come up
with a date together and we've got to
work on this together that's the
foundation of FPU is together
decision-making and for whatever reason
he's not hearing it yeah so if your
marriage or his emotional capacity
doesn't allow him to hear you when you
don't have children in the room they're
asleep you're used to the white noise of
toddlers but most people can't
concentrate with that crap so they're
asleep and you take his two hands in
your two hands and you look in his eyes
and you say listen to me carefully I
can't stay here anymore I'm leaving
mm-hmm mm-hmm so I think we ought to
leave this is not okay anymore mm-hmm if
he can't hear you when you do that and
you haven't cut through all the clutter
of everything because we've talked about
this before guys don't get subtlety you
have to be very direct look directly
into his eyes he has to hear you with no
emotion no side crap and you go I'm done
I'm done
mm-hmm I love your mom but I can't stay
here anymore and I know we had a goal of
trying to do this but it's not working
this is driving me crazy
on a scale of one to ten this is a 12
the funds the fire alarms are going and
if you can't hear me we're gonna have to
sit down with a pastor and begin
marriage counseling because I am leaving
this place
and he has to hear he has to hear that
and if he can't hear that then then you
got a pretty dull dude and you got some
other is you got other issues in your
marriage yeah there's other stuff going
on and so you guys will need to sit down
and to begin some marriage counseling to
save your marriage because you've got
other stuff that this is justice is just
the symptom then if this is the real
problem then it just you transfer and
you guys nothing step two you can do
baby step two anywhere just no matter
how fast it works that's all and I want
to honor the guy who's saying okay we've
got this plan we're gonna get out of
debt here's the map here's the date
here's the analytics here's the whatever
frontal lobe nonsense but guys when you
do that man you burn up people's souls
well I mean you you you can run like
that as long as she's running with you
that's what I mean but this is this is a
situation where she's not running with
you anymore and it's because the
mother-in-law hijacked your plan and it
was a cute idea it was cool it was it
was a good idea as long as she was cute
but she ain't cute I mean you know just
doesn't work anymore
and not many people can do that but
that's hard not many people can do that
particularly in Anglo households hmm
Hispanics are much better at it yeah
they're much more family they love you I
don't know I don't know how they deal
with it but they do a better job that
culture does a lot better job with it
but um it's it's much more standard so
to speak but Anglos ma'am we don't go
back home well we just don't we don't
let go well well and there's in there
nurse mom yeah good well we've been
picking on mom all day today but anyway
my mom's awesome yeah well so there you
go that's how that works and so your
friends and whatever else just there you
heat it up just need yeah just that guy
but yeah I think it's a the thing is
this you can pay a price and you could
even put up with her mm-hmm
as long as you can see the end of it you
gotta have it you got of a finish line
you gotta have a finish line and it's
got to be before my emotional tank is
completely dry that's right you know the
little thing on the dashboard is reading
I got 46 miles left before I'm out of
gas and it's blinking at you and that
the thing says 30 miles okay I think
we're gonna make it yeah but
it says 300 miles screw it we're out of
gas or almost worse when it you don't
know how far you're going yeah that's
work remember the football coach that
would say you'd say how long were you
gonna run and say until I get tired well
I get tired of watching you
I'd rather row we're gonna run a hundred
until you throw up a lot that's right
yeah that guy put it put it put a
deadline for gonna do something crazy
like living monk today so it up with a
lot of pain if you know when it's gonna
be put a deadline on there that's right
she's gonna take about 30 seconds hold
your breath by threw a pillow okay gotta
net so you know it's just you can you
can do this but you got to have a
deadline and you guys got to be willing
to work together even you know you're
told your tune might change if you knew
it's gonna be two months but when it
feels like it might be two years or who
knows